[Music]
life doesn't happen to you
it happens for you
[Music]
sometimes i think that's the only thing
that's important really you know it's
just letting each other know we're here
reminding each other that we're part of
a larger self
you are the vanguard of knowledge and
consciousness
a new wave in a vast ocean of
possibilities
on the other side of that door there's a
world starving for new ideas new
leadership i've been out there for 30
years it can be rough out there
but that's okay
how will you serve the world
what do they need
that your talent can provide
that's all you have to figure out
as someone who's done what you're about
to go and do
i can tell you from experience the
effect you have on others is the most
valuable currency there is
am i choosing to free people from
concern got me to the top of a mountain
look where i am
look what i get to do it really is
extraordinary to me i did something
that made people
present their best selves to me wherever
i go
we are the light that shines through
all else is just smoke and mirrors
distracting but not truly compelling
i've often said that i wish people could
realize all their dreams and wealth and
fame and
so that they could see that it's not
where you're going to find your sense of
completion
like many of you
i was concerned about going out into the
world and doing something bigger than
myself until someone smarter than myself
made me realize that there is nothing
bigger than myself my soul is not
contained within the limits of my body
my body is contained within the
limitlessness of my soul one unified
field of nothing dancing
for no particular reason except maybe to
comfort and entertain itself as that
shift happens in you
you won't be feeling the world you'll be
felt by it you'll be embraced by it
the imagination is always manufacturing
scenarios both good and bad and the ego
tries to keep you trapped in the
multiplex of the mind our eyes are not
viewers they are also projectors
that are running a second story over the
picture that we see in front of us all
the time
fear is writing that script and the
working title is i'll never be enough
no matter what you gain ego will not let
you rest
it will tell you that you cannot stop
until you've left an indelible mark on
the earth until you've achieved
immortality
relax and dream up a good life just
about letting the universe know what you
want and working toward it while letting
go of how it comes to pass take a chance
on faith
not religion but faith
not hope but faith
i don't believe in hope hope is a beggar
hope walks through the fire and faith
leaps over you are ready and able to do
beautiful things in this world
it's our intention our intention is
everything nothing happens on this
planet without it not one single thing
has ever been accomplished without
intention i was two people my whole life
i was in the living room entertaining
people being a monkey you know doing my
thing for the company and
and trying to relieve my mother who was
suffering
she had everything under the sun that
was nagging at her and she was depressed
and i wanted her
to be free
and i wanted her to realize
her life was worth something because she
gave birth to someone who was worth
something
and then i would go into my room
and i would sit
with a legal pad
i was a little kid
i would sit there
and i would try to figure out what it
meant what it was all about
why are we here
what is this
and one day i read something from buddha
that said that all spirituality is about
relieving suffering and i suddenly
realized
that's what i'm doing in the other room
and i'm aligned my purpose is aligned
with this
so
i felt incredibly lucky i lose sight of
that all the time i get caught up in
different concerns and ego concerns
but i'm so lucky to be a part of this
community and to do something that is of
value
and i really cherish that and we are all
one thing it really is true
yeah i would visualize having directors
interested in me and people that i
respected uh saying you know i like your
work or whatever that is and uh i would
visualize things coming to me that i
wanted or whatever this was in like 1987
85 yeah and i had nothing at that time
all it really was for me was kind of
making me feel better i would drive home
and think well i do have these things
and they're out there i just don't have
a hold of them yet but they're out there
i wrote myself a check for 10 million
dollars
for acting services rendered and i gave
myself five years
or three years maybe and
and i dated it thanksgiving 1995.
and i put it in my wallet and i kept it
there and it deteriorated and
deteriorated and stuff and uh just
before
thanksgiving 1995 i found out that i was
going to make 10 million dollars on dumb
dumb and dumber yeah yeah
i mean the truman show was a was a
another moment where i had to kind of
deal with uh well you're not allowed to
do that you know you've presented
yourself one way yeah and uh you know
it's it's a tough thing to convince
people that there's something more or
that they might want to see something
different but i've always believed all
the way along i believe that that it was
about a spark right it was about
who you are as a person it's about your
soul
it's about not necessarily i mean you do
what you do so well
but there is something about you
that uh is attractive to people in a way
that uh they want to sit and watch you
for an hour and and and listen to you
and listen to your insights but it's
about you and who you are
what is it worth and that's what i've
come to so many times in my career in my
life is that i've said
the safe road is going to pay off there
are there are many payoffs to it but i
can't be there
and
and have my soul be on a completely
different track i i just
it's always worth losing to me it is
it's always worth risking if this other
side of me is not a popular one in the
in the scheme of things as far as movie
tickets go then you know what i'll i'll
find a way to sneak it in there i'll
make a plan i will show myself you know
i will find a way and even if i'm not as
popular i will live in that area i will
i will expand myself you know
i started out with many many desires as
far as this business goes and uh
i've so surpassed all of them it
it's not as meaningful to me anymore i
really love the work itself i've
examined myself on several occasions why
am i really doing this am i doing this
because i want to be famous i think
there was an element to that when i
started out
i wanted to be a rain maker i think i
wasn't necessarily seen
as much or as
intently as i wanted to be when i was a
kid i had a job
at least in my own mind and that was to
make my mother feel better
she was
very ill in many ways and so it was to
make her feel better and i think
ultimately
i imitated my father he was a very funny
guy but also i i felt some need i don't
know whether they created it or i
created it but i felt the need
to make them feel that their life was
worthwhile that they did something
special just by the very fact that they
brought me into the world so from a very
young age i wanted to convince them that
i was a miracle
and then i wanted to convince the world
that i was america
you know everybody's looking for bliss
you know in some way or another i think
i've come to the realization lately that
uh bliss comes in waves everybody but he
gets a certain amount of it
in between it's just hard work being in
this body and that it is the unwise
person to expect bliss will be there all
the time absolutely but you look for it
you look for it you wonder why you're
off the beam all the time or whatever so
i'm constantly examining myself i
probably do it too much i've always over
thought everything my desire is my only
problem in this world your appetite my
appetite yeah absolutely to prove
everything and to be everything when you
put some desire in the forefront of your
life
that everything else starts to suffer
i understand that i understand that
because i've gone that way and then i
had to pull myself back or whatever but
it's the yearning that can be something
very positive can create wonderful
things when it makes you uh negate your
life and the people in your life when it
makes you bear false witness you know
and
sell somebody out it's just not worth
having you know that yearning is the
tough part yearning to to kind of have
that but not make it completely uh
consume you
i believe in the universe i believe in
the horn of plenty i believe in
cornucopia you know so i'm not afraid of
tom cruise and what his movies do and i
can enjoy it and i can enjoy russell
crowe because
there is so much in the universe we all
you know can feed from it and there's
enough for everybody to risk being seen
is the toughest thing in the world we're
all very shy people you said something
about your parents that just fascinated
me at a certain point they were just
waiting for the end yeah
yeah and uh
absolutely lovely people right but kind
of lost heart you know my father lost
his job and that that hurt attrition of
life had taken its toll yes absolutely
and i think at a certain point they
weren't enjoying it anymore they weren't
they were just kind of waiting around
uh and i saw that early on and i said no
i can't have that i have to break that
cycle and i'm wary of it myself
about my motivations about
my
allegiances
about
what i'm expressing in the world
you know just my day-to-day uh you know
contact with people the idea that you
know if people come up to me and say i
love you uh you know i i try extra hard
to give them energy you know to make it
something that isn't about me it's about
them and this moment whatever it is
you know i'm constantly
trying to figure out where i'm at and
whether i'm
whether i'm
corrupting myself or or not or i used to
sit up there you know
and open my arms and imagine a giant
funnel
of uh of gifts could come right in from
the universe honestly you could you know
cut to me there i'm like
like this and uh and if nothing else it
made me feel
more positive about where i was i drove
down from a hall and drive every every
night
that i went up there feeling that i was
one of the biggest actors in hollywood i
was doing wonderful work that made
people happy i owned all that that was
it you know i guess you know what i own
when you think about it is is my faith
that's what i own that's about it faith
in the universe faith in myself yeah
that's all i have i'm just excited
really about always changing about
crossing back and forth across the river
and throwing the hounds off the trail
i love that and if i feel like i've been
figured out boy look out i will become
something completely different you know
might not want to become something
completely different but express
something completely different i always
felt like if the world is going crazy
i'll be calm
and if uh and if
they're calm i'll be the one hanging off
the chandelier
[Music]
if you had a day where nobody would
recognize you i don't think i'd be that
different honestly i dropped the whole
trying to be something for somebody a
long time ago so i pretty much walk
through the world except when i want to
be funny or i want to do something
outrageous i don't have any trouble
being myself and i don't have any
trouble saying no when i mean no when
i don't feel there is a you know
pressing
uh responsibility to please everyone i'm
not unkind to people i love people i
would much prefer saying hello and who
are you and what are you doing today
then uh giving a selfie because selfies
stop the world you know they stop life
you then go
yeah and it's going on instagram uh to
give people a false sense
of relevance people talk about
depression all the time the difference
between depression and sadness sadness
is just you know from happenstance
whatever happened or didn't happen for
you or you know
grief or whatever it is and depression
is
your body saying
you
i don't want to be this character
anymore
i don't want to hold up this this avatar
that you've created in the world it's
too much for me deep rest your body
needs to be depressed it needs deep rest
from the character that you've been
trying to play i act because i'm broken
in a lot of pieces
and uh acting gives me a chance to
reconfigure those pieces into a thousand
different things uh that are positive
for people who watch was there a moment
where you first sort of realized like
i want to be a performer this is the
thing that i want to do with my life
uh there was never any other choice from
the time i that there was consciousness
in the body
i was i was looking at a man named percy
my dad who was
the
most incredible character that you'd
ever meet if you met him for five
minutes you thought you knew him for 50
years
and he wrapped everyone that came into
our house in stories and jokes and
i became his calling at a certain point
and he was always super behind me but
from the first time i can remember him
just lighting up the room you know and
him just like
wrapping everybody in a story or
whatever and and going oh that's that's
the thing i want to do you know that's
that's what i want to be
my father could have been a great
comedian but he didn't believe that that
was possible for him and so he made a
conservative choice instead he got a
safe job as an accountant and when i was
12 years old
he was let go from that safe job
and our family had to do whatever we
could to survive
i learned many great lessons from my
father
not the least of which was that you can
fail at what you don't want so you might
as well take a chance on doing what you
love you know i watched the effect of my
father's love and humor
and how it altered the world around me
and i thought
that's something to do
that's something worth my time
it wasn't long before i started acting
up you know people would come over to
the house and they'd be greeted by a
seven-year-old throwing himself down a
large flight of stairs
they would say what happened
and i would say i don't know let's check
the replay
i'd go back to the top of the stairs and
come back down in slow motion
now fear
is going to be a player in your life
but you get to decide how much you can
spend your whole life imagining ghosts
worrying about the pathway to the future
but all there will ever be
is what's happening here
and the decisions we make in this moment
which are based in either love or fear
so many of us choose our path out of
fear disguised as practicality
what we really want seems impossibly out
of reach and ridiculous to expect so we
never dare to ask the universe for it
when i was about 28
after a decade as a professional
comedian i realized one night in l.a
that the purpose of my life had always
been to free people from concern just
like my dad
the only one i hadn't freed
was myself
and that's when my search for identity
deepened
i wondered who i'd be without my fame
who would i be if i said things that
people didn't want to hear
or if i defied their expectations of me
and that peace that we're after lies
somewhere beyond personality beyond the
perception of others beyond invention
and disguise even beyond effort itself
you can join the game fight the wars
play with form all you want
but to find real peace you have to let
the armor go your need for acceptance
can make you invisible in this world
don't let anything stand in the way of
the light that shines through this form
risk being seen
in all of your glory
your job is not to figure out how it's
going to happen for you but to open the
door in your head and when the door
opens in real life just walk through it
and don't worry if you miss your queue
because there's always doors opening
they keep opening
and when i say
life doesn't happen to you
it happens for you i really don't know
if that's true
i'm just making a conscious choice to
perceive challenges as something
beneficial so that i can deal with them
in the most productive way
you'll come up with your own style
that's part of the fun
you are ready and able to do beautiful
things in this world and after you walk
through those doors today you will only
ever have two choices
love or fear
choose love
and don't ever let fear turn you against
your playful heart what's happening
right now inside everybody is they're
going who am i
and they're depressed people go like oh
jim's been depressed and stuff well yeah
i was depressed when i was trying to be
the wizard of oz but now i know that oz
is a character you know i think
everybody deals with that everybody
walks around and they go like why am i
depressed well it's because you're
trying to be something for the world
you know and as soon as you
let that go
better things happen
because they're just happening
it's not uh
you know now it's just sadness you know
sadness comes happiness comes it's the
weather that
flies by in the sky it doesn't sit on
you long enough to drown you a few
months ago i woke up
and
i suddenly got it i understood suddenly
how thought was just an illusory thing
and how
thought is responsible for if not all
most of the suffering
we experience
and then
i suddenly felt
like i was looking at these thoughts
from another perspective and i wondered
who is it that's aware that i'm thinking
and suddenly i was thrown into this
expansive
amazing feeling
of freedom
from myself from my
you know when i go to sleep at night i'm
not just a guy going to sleep
i'm two-time golden globe winner
jim carrey going
to get some well-needed shut-eye
and when i dream i don't just dream any
old dream
no sir
i dream about being three-time golden
globe winning
actor jim carrey
because then i would be enough
[Applause]
it would finally be true
and i could stop this
this terrible search
for what i know ultimately won't fulfill
me
[Music]
you